Welcome back to another episode
of the Wine Down.
Today we are joined
by Alexander Hodge,
who plays Molly's love interest,
Andrew,
to discuss "Lowkey Trippin'."
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
This was a big episode
for Andrew and Molly.
Yeah.
What do you think this trip
says about their relationship?
I mean I don't think
Andrew and Molly, uh,
I don't think they take
family lightly, either of them.
So the fact that
somebody's meeting
someone else's family,
is like,
things are getting pretty--
pretty serious
between these two.
Can you talk about
Andrew's journey?
Ooh. Yeah, I think Andrew--
Andrew's been confronted,
I think, for the first time,
Andrew's sort of been
really challenged
by a strong personality
in a relationship.
So this is the first time
where he's been like,
"Oh, okay. I need to contribute
in some way
that makes me uncomfortable."
And so I think mainly
that's been being vulnerable,
and opening up, and like,
you know,
just being an Asian man,
and being raised
the way he was,
talking about things
that don't make him feel strong
or make him feel insecure,
are really difficult for him.
What do you think, sort of,
is going through Molly's head,
uh, during her argument
with Victor,
about her overreacting
to the towel lady?
(SIGHS) It's--
I think it's the first time
that Molly's had
to defend her existence
to somebody who is
of Andrew's side
of the relationship.
So it's like the first time
that Molly's had to explain
what being black is like
to Victor.
And Andrew is kind of
on the side,
but also at the same time,
is-- is just trying
to understand
where both sides
are coming from.
And I think in that moment,
what he was trying to do,
by trying to diffuse
the situation,
wasn't actually helpful
because he actually
made Molly feel more isolated.
This is our first episode
out of the country.
What was it like?
I think it was--
it infused, I think,
a new energy into the show
to also take a show
that on-paper is about,
you know,
these two black women that
live in a very specific part
of L.A.,
and take them and put them--
and to see why people travel.
-Yeah.
-And to take the show
and not just show, you know,
obviously, us filming there,
it's one thing
to see black people, you know,
in front of the camera,
behind the camera.
Out of the country, you know,
filming a television show.
But I think, also,
it does a lot even on screen
to see that,
'cause we do travel.
No Issa.
I mean how was that for you
on your side?
It was a blessing.
I've been waiting
for this moment
for four seasons.
ALEXANDER: She said
let's get three more.
And it was-- Yes,
let's get three.
Next season, woo.
-I'm not gonna be in none of it.
-Not gonna be in none of it.
But I do want to talk about
just the presence
that Issa has on this trip.
Um... (CHUCKLES)
So I think,
even though Issa was not
appearing in this episode,
Issa definitely featured
heavily.
I feel like it's affected Molly
so much
because Issa and Molly
are just such a strong presence
in each other's lives.
I do wonder if the fight
with Issa hadn't happened,
and if she didn't have
that burden on her trip,
if she would have gone so hard
on Victor.
Victor was being a bit
of a dick.
Mm-hmm, Victor was a dick
for sure.
Yeah.
I think Victor was the victim
of displacement of her anger.
And I think that's
what's interesting
about episode six and seven.
Even though they're not
in each other's episodes,
their presence is felt.
That's how strong
these two women are
in each other's lives.
And how much,
by them not dealing with it,
it's still a presence
they have to face
in some way.
And so I think that's
what's great about the end
when Yvonne is like,
"I have to sort of
start to deal with this."
When do you feel like
it's right to react...
or to let it go?
Speaking as myself,
or what I would like myself
-to do?
-Speaking as yourself.
-React.
-React all day?
So the towel--
From the towel lady
-to the fight in the jacuzzi.
-Yeah.
-Those are your moves.
-Well I need to--
I need to work on it.
I'm actively working on this...
myself.
Doctor Rhonda is available.
It is-- Look, I have my own
Doctor Rhonda,
and she helps me-- I--
I react a lot.
I feel like reacting
might not be the issue.
Overreacting is an issue.
Reacting is not an issue.
But I think when you react,
it's important
to like find a way
to maintain capacity to listen.
Okay, well we can't thank you
enough for joining us this week.
Be sure to join us next week
for a new episode
of the Wine Down.
-Cheers.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪